so when you were 11 talk about your
filmmaking rise from that point what
could you my meteoric rise when I was 11
I just started at some point around 10
or 11 I realized that there were these
people called directors and writers that
really did the stuff I think my parents
are big into Hitchcock and Kubrick and
it would watch his documentaries about
them on our PBS station and and the
Spielberg sort of entered the national
consciousness around that time it was
after it was right before raiders of the
lost ark and so they're all these things
oh you know then this distractor that
knows young kid director who's golly the
biggest movies of all time jaws and
Close Encounters are his now he's
working with George Lucas the other big
guy and so there's all this awareness
and I think at that point I started
thinking oh obviously they do all the
stuff they come up with a store and they
create the feel and work with the actors
and do these things and so I remember
picking up a camera and I we all know he
already had a super 8 camera my parents
had been putting in some movies that I
acted in horrible stuff I picked it up
and I started learning how to make
movies and and I didn't my parents
didn't educate me there was no it was no
it was complete ground-up education like
I would see Spielberg movies and I'd see
these you know these great dolly into
face shots like I want to do that I
didn't realize they were moving the
camera I thought they were to zoom again
so I try zooming I could never get this
room to look right and one day I moved
the camera forward and I'm gonna look
through the footage of like oh well
that's that's the moves literally
learning you look at my early stuff it's
almost like the evolution of silent
cinema why it's all wide shots and
silent and then it's like and then we
very slowly begin to discover the medium
shot the close-up and editing and and
moving the camera and then my parents
bought me a sound camera when I was 16
so suddenly there was sound didn't it
was it was almost like the history of
cinema replayed through this stupid kid
so I learned everything you know ground
up
you